welcome to this video playing shark
until 55 who was that nobody knows this
Croatian para boy it's about this little
thing in the micro Asia it's different
I'm sorry about that paraguay Jackie
came so we get done bull go india i
played this recently with success so
let's repeated not even going for g3
black has a simple way of playing now
I'm just taking c3 and playing 94 thats
kind of them the easy way to handle the
thing but he didn't go for it
yeah okay still it doesn't want to take
one two three okay so 86 okay go to e5
now maybe do that then go for F for the
only thing ever normally you want the
Queen on f3 in this kind of position but
it's probably not that bad the way it is
okay so so what about is this idea no
there are ideas technical ideas like 95
Bishop h7 they're probably not working
or are they 95 95 Bishop h7 check King
h8 Queen f5 is this working
but maybe it is if it's not working okay
it's just a blitz game check Bishop c8
Queen h5 is dangerous g6 Bishop g6 is
also quite dangerous so yeah maybe
interesting i've got two pawns and some
crude but dangerous attacking ideas okay
this is not a move I looked at too much
but it's not bad of course quite
typically missing a simple movie okay so
what now he's maybe I have Bishop g6 but
he can take e 5 which is probably
completely enough
it's quite simple and I didn't see it I
did not see that move
bishop g6 is not leading anywhere
absolutely no we're actually quite
embarrassing and I cannot cannot move
the bishop anywhere
well that's amazingly bad or any way to
even continue their simply didn't think
about this
for Luke age three should have played
that quicker actually since the only
it's the only thing that it's a little
bit interesting maybe maybe probably not
working either but they're only oh ok so
he just takes it 46mm you why not but I
might have some kind of long diagonal
thing going for me at least so 96 stupid
probably I have to move the Queen here
that is effort that was total crap right
this idea was not working in the
slightest absolutely not in the
slightest I'm 22 pieces down here the
worst thing is you can always return
stuff and be totally okay Mia and Bishop
c8 next that's the problem it's so easy
so easy to play
wow what a stupid idea
yeah i'm down everything so he really
wants to trade them you really wants to
okay 95
nope time warning
maybe we get some funny made I got I got
so much I'm down so much material here
he has tons of nice ways probably to
check made me
check check I can just take G chatter
hey okay yeah it's a bit down it's a
very simple way to do it I still have
pawns okay okay hmm those pawns getting
anywhere fortunately not okay yeah it
was just was just very stupid audience I
just I just didn't know to work at all
but as I said when I play it is just a
blitz game so so why not just once in a
while try something but Knight f6 was a
pretty easy way to refute that okay oh
it's all about this position I should
play something normal here oh the comp
actually gives that move check but rook
f3 now and not Queen a 5 which is just
not working at all look here okay for
rook age three this is given us equal by
the engine that's quite funny hmm
interesting threatening this with made
oh why is better amazing what about this
kind of thing or this this is awesome
given by the comp I can play o Queen B
one is actually good for so maybe this
was maybe this was working well but ok
this is a moot point I really did not I
just wanted to go Queen f5 intending
this out of this and neither six just
refutes the whole thing after that I'm
just fishing there with the
being down everything and yet multiple
ways when it was very easy for black so
basically a suicidal way to play this 95
and Queen f5 okay thanks for watching